teame
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
いただいた仕様書に基づいて見積書を作成させていただきました
いかがでしょうかうんん
いただいた使用傷に基づいて見積書を作成させていただきました
普段もっと高い金額になりますが今回は特別に下げております
飲みに行くか
tan tan
スイバ土曜日にバーベキューをしようかと思ってるんだけどクルー
もういいね行く行くうん
土曜日に時間あるんもあるけど実はバーベキューをしようかと思ってるんだけども狂う
といいね行く行く
うん
2019年10月12日の午前中を得ている
調べてみるちょっと待ってね実はバーベキューをしようかと思ってるんだけど
くるーいいね
いきたいな
あった後
うんそっか
ごめん sony 歯医者行くんだあじゃあまた次回
すいません
あっ申し訳ございますブーンん
この度をと作業に作業に必要とされるものを全て揃っているかと思っていろんな方々に
お手数をおかけしてしまい歴も注意して状況を3回以上確認してから来てよ
pl
検討します
前回紹介させて頂いた提案なんですがいかがでしょうか
検討します社長この椅子を使うと効率が良くなるみたいなんですがいかがでしょうか
検討します検討していただいてもよろしいですか
deni
いやー素晴らしい実績ですね明日菜とマーケティング担当者からマーケティング部長に
なります
練習も50万円ほどあかりますありがとうございます
いやー素晴らしい実績ですねましたあなたはマーケティング担当者からマーケティング
部長取ります
練習も5000円ほど上がりますありがとうございます
いやー素晴らしい実績ですね明日あなたはマーケティング担当者から会計部長になり
ます
あっありがとう
me
初めまして動機ですよろしくお願いしますうんん
堂原と申しますよろしくお願い致しますうんん
deji
wh